der Esel der einer Karotte in der rennt
die er nie erreichen kann ist wohl eines
der ältesten memes überhaupt diese
Zeichnung ist über 100 Jahre alt und
stammt aus dem Jahr 1916 aber sogar in
Minecraft findet das Prinzip Anwendung
um ein Schwein zu steuern vor 5 Jahren
hat der geniale Youtuber William Osman
versucht seinen Hund mit demselben
Prinzip fernzusteuern aber den Versuch
dann als gescheitert bezeichnet und da
wir erst vor kurzem ein ganz normales
Auto in ein ferngesteuertes umgewandelt
haben finde ich ist es an der Zeit 5
Jahre später das Kapitel ferngesteuerte
Hund erneut anzugehen mit unserer
kleinen mai denn eine Gemeinsamkeit hat
sie mit einem Esel sie liebt Karotten
[Musik]
dieses Video wird unterstützt von
tales.com mehr dazu später technisch
gesehen haben wir dafür schon viel
Vorarbeit geleistet beim Auto
fernsteuern dafür haben wir bereits eine
Fernbedienung über einen Empfänger mit
einem Servomotor verbunden und wenn man
jetzt den Steuerknüppel betätigt bewegt
der sich nach oben und unten beim Auto
haben wir damit das Gaspedal gedrückt
und diese Elektronik kommt auch in
unserem Prototypen wieder zum Einsatz
das Projekt steht und fällt mit der
Frage ob die Mal überhaupt Bock drauf
hat finde dieses entweder geil oder
überhaupt nicht geil und deshalb haben
wir mit einem Meterstab einen recht
simplen Prototypen gebaut um zu schauen
wie Mai auf eine für sie doch recht
ungewohnte Konstruktion reagiert denn
auch wenn die meisten Hunde bei allem
was mit Futter zu tun hat direkt eine
Party machen findet man manchmal sogar
Stehlampen suspekt also das hier ist
meist Geschirr da kommt jetzt eigentlich
noch so eine Leine dran aber alleine
sind ja einfach aus der Steinzeit wenn
man das krasser Fernsteuerung braucht
man keine Leine mehr genau das Geschirr
braucht das ist quasi wie ein Halsband
nur halt in sicherer rutscht nicht ab
und ist nicht unangenehm da muss jetzt
irgendwie das Teil hier drauf montieren
ja ich mache das einfach mal mit Kabel
auseinander einmal hier rum einmal hier
rum okay das sieht doch schon mal gut
aus man muss die Dinge erstmal
kennenlernen damit du den vertraust und
da helfen ein bisschen nach ein bisschen
Bestechung sitzt fein und dadurch ja
[Musik]
und schon wieder weg
ja
erstmal skeptisch sein das ist auch
besser so jetzt fehl ich mir mal so eine
Leckerbissen auf eine Schnur drauf dafür
habe ich ja die Löcher gemacht jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen Hundefutter geboren
ist ja logisch weil irgendwie muss ich
das ja auch daran befestigen
so und die Schnur klebe ich dann an den
Zollstock dran ich wollte jetzt nicht
das Foto direkt leben weil es natürlich
vielleicht nicht ganz so gesund mit dem
Klebstoff
also sie ist neugierig aber sind keine
Angst davor
außer sie denkt sich schon hey was
passiert da ich glaube die Konstruktion
wird noch nicht halten so wie sie gerade
ist sie so verrückt aus ja man denkt sie
jetzt wo ist das Leckerli es ist direkt
im Kopf ja und da hast du gekriegt kann
man lenken ja man kann die mal ein
bisschen lenken also die werden auf
jeden Fall hinterher schauen
sie ist voll verwirrt also die
Technologie funktioniert
fast es gibt noch ein bisschen zu sehr
aber meist interessiert die auf jeden
Fall Bock aber damit mai nicht länger
über einen Kabel an einem Elektronik
kaufen festhängt muss die gesamte
Elektronik noch viel kompakter werden
damit sie in ein eigenes dafür
entworfenes Gehäuse passt das Gehäuse
hält auch den Motor ordentlich und hat
unten eine Rundung damit es nicht
unangenehm für Mal wird zu guter Letzt
kann die Mail natürlich nicht die 20 kg
schwere Autobatterie tragen die unseren
Prototyp Version 1 betrieben hat aber
zum Glück sind unsere Film nicht Akkus
viel kleiner und zufällig auch technisch
wieder für geschaffen
ist ist es diese Stromkabel hier die
Batterie reinzukriegen und dafür zu
sorgen dass sie halten weil die Rutschen
jetzt schnell raus ich versuche jetzt
noch mal dann Upgrade zu machen indem
ich einfach noch mal hier ein paar
Aderendhülsen drauf
drückt
so steckt wieder sehr gut der Minuspol
hier wird auch noch getunt
der steckt auch wieder so jetzt ist das
Fest und er hier funktioniert auch noch
und dann viel kompakter ist die ganze
Elektronik vorher
[Musik]
nein du kriegst jetzt ein Geschirr
angezogen und Kopf rein wie geplant Pan
kommt das drauf okay also der Radius ist
nicht unbedingt ganz passend wie meist
Rücken also
ein bisschen überschätzt geil
[Musik]
und dafür das mai so einen riesen Mut
bewiesen hat und die Konstruktion echt
locker genommen hat hat sie sich auf
jeden Fall in den Belohnung verdient
oh nein nein
aber nicht mit irgendwelchen random der
Kelly sondern mit individuell auf Sie
angepasst und Hundefutter von taste.com
wie alle Vorlieben das perfekte
Hundefutter dass man sich mit ein paar
wenigen Klicks individuell
zusammenstellen kann wenn euer Hund am
liebsten Rind Huhn Lamm oder Fisch
frisst könnt ihr das wenn ihr wollt
auswählen und auch auf Allergien und
Unverträglichkeiten kann das Futter
abgestimmt werden aber auch auf
Gewichtsabnahme Zunahme und Gewicht
sowie bei dir gell aber freuen sondern
auch hier dank des monatlichen Abos
müsste nämlich nicht mehr schwere
schleppen sondern bekommt alles bequem
vor die hauszüge liefert und falls ihr
meine Pause beim Abo braucht oder
irgendwas am Essensplan ändern wollt
könnt ihr das ganz einfach online
einstellen was wir besonders
Konflikte und einstellbare Becher müsste
man immer exakt die richtige Portion hat
weil wir seitdem das Essen nicht immer
extra abwägen müssen mit dem Code tomory
erhaltet ihr über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung einen ganzen Monat
lang kostenloses individuelles
Hundefutter und zusätzlich noch 75% auf
das restliche Sortiment wie zum Beispiel
Leckerli und die sitzt
und die scheint also probiert
genauso gut unsere Gerätschaft und damit
bei unser meisterplan die Steuern findet
eigentlich nur noch diese Abend der
quasi das Leckerli oder das Hundefutter
vor Mais gesichtsbaum ist ich habe lange
überlegt was man machen könnte irgendwas
ausgefüllt ist aber und im Strich ist so
ein Meterstab den ich übrigens nicht wie
einige Kommentatoren es gerne hätten
Zollstock nennen werde weil ich
arbeitete und nicht mit Zoll ne also ein
gliedermaßen ab dann eben ist einfach
perfekt der ist leicht der ist schön
starr und genau selber auf die Länge und
aufbrauchen aber ich mache noch ein paar
Modifikationen damit das nicht so viel
überlassen mit sich bringt wie bei
unserer vorherigen Version
[Musik]
er soll hier ungefähr hin das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt zwei Löcher eins hier
[Applaus]
das ist ein Verrückter sparen und eins
hier
kommt dann hier rein und da brauche ich
jetzt einfach durch intelligenterweise
vielleicht mit dem Holzbohrer
oh hier gibt es direkt zwei
flanschmuttern die sind perfekt weil
hier direkt so eine große Auflagefläche
haben und ich dann quasi keine
Beilagscheiben drauf ist ja schön
schonend festgehalten wird ich habe
vorher noch so gehatet weil ich ja kein
Zoll benutze ich hier mit
Bus in Zollangaben von der macht keiner
passt einmal
dürfte fest sein
dürfte auch fest sein und die brauchen
auf jeden Fall nicht mehr hier unten so
groß ist die mai jetzt nämlich auch
nicht du machst die ab wie mache ich das
jetzt am schönsten
sieht ein bisschen aus dem Bagger ich
habe noch kurz gecheckt und eigentlich
reichen mir die ersten drei Teile vom
Gliedermaßstab weil das reicht von der
Entfernung eigentlich schon komplett die
oberen beiden braucht überhaupt nicht
ja deshalb kommen die ab und an der
Stelle dafür ein Loch damit das Leckerli
festgebunden werden kann und mit der
Version 2 der Konstruktion geht's dann
raus an die frische Luft
ja so also wir sind jetzt draußen wie
ihr seht das Wetter ist natürlich mega
geil und Mike kriegt jetzt ihr Geschirr
an ja
weg also es funktioniert schon mal
[Musik]
wo ist es ja heute hier okay das ist
geil ich versuche jetzt mal fern zu
steuern
ja
damit sie auch sieht wenn es baumelt und
dann fahren damit sich nicht so hart
baumelt
zu kriegen soll ich keinen Bock mehr
also vielleicht müssen wir die Schnur
einfach ersetzen durch irgendwie
ein Holzstück oder so damit das nicht
immer so baumelt das wäre so das erste
Lied ein bisschen größer machen damit
sie es mir präsent hat oder irgendwas
was stärker wie ich will dass dein
Futter genommen
wir müssen noch dran arbeiten
gell mal so eine süße und damit jetzt
wieder ab in die Werkstatt das erste
Problem das gehoben werden muss ist dass
diese Schnur hier oben immer so hat
baumelt jetzt kommt natürlich irgendwie
ein Draht nehmen das wäre mit Sicherheit
das einfachste allerdings will ich auch
nicht dass der Hund irgendwie ein Draht
rein beißt das ist glaube ich bisschen
hart deswegen würde ich das einmal mit
Pappe machen aus
und dann will ich da gerne drei Leckerli
platzieren ja weil eins war glaube ich
ein bisschen zu wenig das muss schon ein
bisschen
luftmäßig eine Explosion sein soll ich
mir das überlegt dass ich das so rein
mache und eins hält auch ganz gut
so das scheint zu funktionieren ist auch
halbwegs stabil fällt nichts raus und
das muss jetzt irgendwie noch da dran
montiert werden ja Klebeband glaube ich
und damit haben wir zwei Probleme gelöst
einerseits das ist zu wackelig ist
weil das wackelt schon aber das pendelt
sich auch direkt wieder ein außerdem
haben wir jetzt lecker die das deutlich
mehr riecht als Trockenfutter und wir
haben gleich drei Stück damit das im
visuellen Sichtfeld von der Mai noch
Präsente ist ja genau und wir haben das
ganze Ding noch mal ordentlich länger
gemacht perfekt funktioniert
oh nein meinst du mir so leid
ich will nicht so schlecht wir
verarschen den Hund okay also das
funktioniert okay das ist richtig böse
[Musik]
dafür das war nicht die Regeln die wir
abgemacht haben nein also füllen wir die
Leckerli noch mal auf und starten den
nächsten Versuch
es geht hinterher
nach links skeptisch
[Musik]
das Ding einfach auf dem Boden
und ist dann ne der Hund ist einfach zu
schlau der Hund ist einfach zu schlau
aber es klappt auch gleichzeitig immer
besser ja weil sie halt jetzt da schon
was rausgekriegt hat
jetzt ja
sie ist viel zu schlau dieser Hund die
hat aber selber gelernt wie man diesen
Zollstock hier verbiegt um an Säcke
reinzukommen Nein zu Schlaufen mein
Gedanke dahin muss auch schlau ist ist
sich jetzt individuell angepasstes
Hundefutter von face.com zu sichern über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung und
damit sind wir auch schon raus also
macht's gut